SEATTLE.
THANK YOU.
>> Sandra: BRAND-NEW NUMBERS ON
THE ECONOMY JUST IN.
INITIAL JOBLESS CLAIMS SLIGHTLY
HIGHER THAN EXPECTED.
860,000 AMERICANS FILING LAST
WEEK.
PETER NAVARRO JOINS US NOW.
WHAT DOES THAT NEW NUMBER MEAN
FOR OUR ECONOMIC RECOVERY?
ARE WE CLIMBING OUR WAY OUT OF
THIS?
>> THERE IS NO QUESTION WE’RE
CLIMBING OUR WAY OUT OF IT.
THE WAY I LIKE TO LOOK AT IT.
WE’LL LET FOLKS LIKE LARRY
KUDLOW TALK ABOUT THE BIG MACRO.
WHAT I DO FOR THE PRESIDENT IS
WORK ON THE MICROSTUFF.
TODAY HE IS GOING TO WISCONSIN,
TOMORROW MINNESOTA.
AND AT THE MICRO LEVEL I’LL
EXPLAIN WHY WE’LL DO SO WELL IN
BOTH OF THOSE STATES.
IF YOU LOOK AT WISCONSIN YOU
START IN OSHKOSH, THE PRESIDENT
DID A HUGE DEFENSE BUDGET
INCREASE.
WE GOT GREAT -- ONE OF THE
STATE-OF-THE-ART COMBAT VEHICLE
PLANTS THERE NEAR THE GREEN BAY
AREA.
THE SHIPYARD THERE IS BOOMING
WHEN IT WAS ALL BUT DEAD UNDER
THE OBAMA-BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
YOU GO TO WAUSAU.
IT IS CLOSE TO THE DULUTH AREA
AND WHAT IS HAPPENING OVER IN
MINNESOTA IS THERE IS THIS
NATURAL RESOURCE RENAISSANCE
THAT’S COME ABOUT IN LOGGING
BUT PARTICULARLY BECAUSE OF THE
STEEL AND ALUMINUM TARIFFS.
THE WHOLE IRON RANGE UP THERE
IS BOOMING.
THEY MAKE THINGS CALLED
TOCONITE PELLETS AND THEY GO TO
THE STEEL MILLS AROUND THE
MIDWEST.
IF YOU LOOK AT ALL THIS
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY THAT IS THE
RESULT OF THE FOCUS ON
MANUFACTURING, FOCUS ON THE
WORKERS, I THINK THAT’S WHAT
WILL REALLY LIFT THINGS UP AND
BY THE WAY, THERE IS BIG 10
FOOTBALL AS WELL.
PEOPLE ARE HAPPY IN GOPHER AND
BADGER LAND TODAY.
>> Sandra: HE IS HITTING THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL AND HE IS GOING
TO WISCONSIN.
HE SEES SOME WORK TO BE DONE
THERE.
A NARROW MARGIN THAT HE DID
UNEXPECTEDLY WIN THAT STATE IN
2016.
HE IS HEADING TO MOSINEE IN
MARATHON COUNTY TODAY.
THE COUNTY HE CARRIED BACK IN
2016.
WHY THERE, PETER?
>> LOOK, THIS IS THE MOST
ACTIVE PRESIDENT IN TERMS OF
TRAVELING.
WHY HE WILL BE THERE TODAY, HE
WILL BE SOMEWHERE ELSE IN THE
STATE IN ANOTHER WEEK.
THIS PRESIDENT, IT’S
INTERESTING TO WATCH HIS TRAVEL
SCHEDULE COMPARED TO THE JOE
BIDEN NOT EXPRESS.
THIS PRESIDENT IS THE HARDEST
WORKING PRESIDENT YOU HAVE EVER
SEEN.
THINK ABOUT THE TRAVEL SCHEDULE.
WISCONSIN TODAY, MINNESOTA
TOMORROW, NORTH CAROLINA AND
THEN NEXT MONDAY IT IS GOING TO
BE OHIO AND SO WE’RE HITTING IT
HARD.
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS THAT THE
SWING STATES ARE GOING TO BE
REALLY WHAT DETERMINE THIS
ELECTION BUT THEY PLAY RIGHT
INTO DONALD TRUMP’S STRENGTH.
IT IS ALL ABOUT BEING A BLUE
COLLAR PRESIDENT AND THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY BEING THE
PARTY OF THE WORKING CLASS.
>> Sandra: THE RESIDENTS OF
THAT STATE AND THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY WONDERING WHAT HAPPENS
AS FAR AS A RELIEF BILL AND
STIMULUS CHECKS.
YOU HAVE THE PRESIDENT NOW
TALKING ABOUT AN EVEN LARGER
STIMULUS PACKAGE.
HIS PRIORITY HAS BEEN THE $1200
STIMULUS CHECKS.
A TWEET FROM THE PRESIDENT ON
DEMS AND BAIL-OUT MONEY.
HE SAID DEMOCRATS ONLY WANT
BAIL-OUT MONEY FOR BLUE STATES
THAT ARE DOING BADLY.
THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT THE
PEOPLE.
NEVER DID.
MARK MEADOWS WAS ON THIS
NETWORK THIS MORNING DETAILING
WHAT HE SAYS THE PRESIDENT
WANTS.
LISTEN.
>> WHAT NUMBER DID HE TELL YOU
HE WANTS?
>> HE WAS CERTAINLY WILLING TO
EMBRACE THE 1.5 TRILLION NUMBER
THAT WAS PUT OUT IN THE LAST
DAY OR SO.
IT REALLY DEPENDS ON WHAT THE
PRIORITIES ARE.
>> Sandra: ADD TO THAT.
WHAT DOES THE PRESIDENT WANT?
>> TRUST IN MEADOWS HERE.
A NEGOTIATION.
WE DO THAT BEHIND CLOSED DOORS
UNLIKE THE DEMOCRATS WHO LIKE
TO DO IT IN THE ROTUNDA.
THE ONE THING I CAN TELL YOU,
SANDRA, THIS IS NOT NEWS BUT IT
SHOULD BE REPEATED, NANCY
PELOSI IS THE PROBLEM HERE.
THERE IS A LOT OF PEOPLE IN HER
PARTY WHO WANT TO DEAL BECAUSE
THEY UNDERSTAND THE PAIN AND
SUFFERING OF THE PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY WHETHER IT’S NOT HAVING
A JOB OR WHETHER FORCING
EVICTION OR FORECLOSURE.
I’M NOT SURE WHAT’S GOING ON
WITH PELOSI BUT THERE IS
DEFINITELY A DEAL TO BE DONE
WHETHER IT’S 1.5 OR SOMETHING
ELSE.
BUT LOOK --
>> Sandra: WHAT’S IT GOING TO
TAKE?
>> WELL, I THINK TALKING ON
SHOWS LIKE THIS AND RAISING THE
AWARENESS SO THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC PUTS PRESSURE ON CAPITOL
HILL.
NANCY PELOSI APPEARS TO BE THE
OBSTACLE HERE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
HER PARTY WHO WANT HER TO MOVE
OFF THAT DIME.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE SAD TRUTH, I
THINK SHE IS GAMBLING THAT IF
THE ECONOMY IS BAD, PRESIDENT
TRUMP LOSES AND SHE GAINS POWER.
THAT KIND OF CALCULUS, IF THERE
IS ANY TRUTH TO THAT AT ALL, IT
HAS NO PLACE IN THIS GREAT
COUNTRY.
>> Sandra: SHE HAS PUSHED BACK
ON THAT NOTION THAT HAS BEEN
FLOATED OUT THERE.
>> SHE PUSHES BACK ON ALL SORTS
OF NOTION.